mais tout de suite on retrouve génacerus
pour le lancement de son cinquième
festival Diana sur rue alors pourquoi
est-ce que vous avez décidé de créer
votre propre festival
bon ah merci bienvenue au Festival
international du film de Paris je suis
juin par Ethan qui présente en
court-métrage City qui est listé pour
les Oscars et qui screamera vendredi
pourquoi ce festival c'est justement
pour inviter des films Maker à venir du
monde entier puisque Ethan vient de Rome
donc c'est des cinéastes qui viennent du
monde entier vous avez d'autres Inès
avec vous oui oui tout à fait ben
justement on va on va vous les présenter
donc on espère que techniquement ça va
fonctionner mais
parce que là vous êtes en plein Paris
faut peut-être le préciser vous êtes à
côté du cinéma Le Champeau qui s'est
situé à Paris exactement et pour ceux
qui sont encore dans le RER vous pouvez
toujours nous rejoindre des 78
et alors peut-être juste avant de
retrouver les cinéastes quel est le
principe de ce festival Jeanne
alors c'est pas pour rien qu'on est sur
rue des Écoles puisque le festival a
avant tout vocation à promouvoir
l'éducationnelle et la francophilie
c'est pour ça que nos réalisateurs que
vous pouvez d'ailleurs contre par
recevoir d'ici puisqu'ils sont au
premier étage de ce magnifique
restaurant parisien viennent des cinq
continents depuis le début de la semaine
ils prennent ici leur film nous avons
des panels et des discussions également
un laboratoire en collaboration avec la
fabrique des récits et l'objectif c'est
avant tout de développement
international l'inclusion dans les dans
nos fictions et plus largement on espère
dans nos vies
et donc il y aura aussi des remises des
prix à la fin
tout à fait le festival ouvre ce soir
avec le premier long métrage de
Clémentine Célarié dont vous avez parlé
qui est formidable c'est un film qui
s'appelle Pierre et Jeanne c'est son
premier long-métrage du réalisatrice et
le festival se poursuit jusqu'au 15
février avec la remise de prix et le 14
février un moyen-métrage Suisse qui a
été nominé aux Oscars l'année dernière
et qui parle de la liberté on vous donne
tous rendez-vous juste ici alors je
rebondis vous avez parlé du film de
Clémentine Célarié qui a réalisé du coup
Pierre et Jeanne on va en parler juste
après mais avant regardons un extrait de
ce film de la bande-annonce
[Musique]
à votre fille Jeanne mademoiselle Jeanne
Roland c'est très généreux
merci mon frère
merci
alors ce film il tourne autour d'un
frère et d'une soeur c'est un peu une
histoire
déchirante entre le frère et sa sœur et
du coup Clémentine s'est marié s'est
inspiré du livre Pierre et Jean de Guy
de Maupassant
absolument et pour raconter cette
histoire à la rassembler un casque
absolument exceptionnel Loris Freeman
Philippe Huchon également avec la
participation de Mathieu Amalric c'est
formidable parce que nous ici au
Festival international du film de Paris
on est vraiment très heureux de célébrer
le cinéma indépendant là il s'agit d'un
premier film il s'agit aussi d'un coup
pour le festival avant à long métrage
australien précédemment vu au Festival
de Cannes dans la section civile et
c'est formidable de pouvoir raconter une
histoire de famille il faut dire qu'ici
pour cette cinquième édition
anniversaire nous mettons vraiment à
l'honneur le thème de la famille de la
parenté puisque les courts métrages dont
le film d'Ethan Sissi traite justement
de ces thèmes qui sont à nos yeux très
importants et qu'on a vraiment tenu à
mettre en valeur cette semaine alors
durant le festival sera également
diffusé le documentaire Pioneer Pioneer
inkirt désolé pour pour l'accent c'est
pionnière en jupe en français ce
documentaire il met notamment en avant
les obstacles que peuvent rencontrer
des femmes durant leur carrière
absolument c'est vrai que le thème de
l'inclusion est très important pour nous
et il est important dans nos fictions il
est également important dans nos
industries et le Festival international
du film de Paris à vocation avant tout
de rassembler un public de
professionnels d'amateurs et également
d'étudiants et l'idée c'est de réfléchir
ensemble comment est-ce qu'on va
construire le monde de demain donc dès
demain après les festivités de
l'ouverture se tiendra le laboratoire
des scénaristes en partenariat avec
network
Issa et la fabrique des récits ainsi que
l'association Ensemble Ukraine qui fait
un travail absolument phénoménal et avec
ce laboratoire qui est inaugural pour
cette année l'idée c'est de continuer à
travailler ensemble pour trouver des
solutions dans nos fictions et dans nos
vies pour justement rendre cette
bataille moins difficile et pour
toujours parler plus de cinéma
et est-ce que vous pouvez nous présenter
un petit peu les autres films qui seront
à l'affiche
oui tout à fait nous avons une très
belle sélection de longs-métrages de
courts métrages également de scénario
que j'ai mentionné on n'oublie pas bien
sûr à la catchu donc le moyen métrage
Suisse déjà mentionné qui est réalisé
par Maria Brandon nous sommes très
honorés de recevoir ce film la semaine
prochaine puisqu'il s'agit d'un film
nominé aux Oscars qui traite d'un thème
tout à fait universel celui de la
liberté dans le cadre en l'occurrence
d'une famille au Kirghizistan et
l'objectif de la réalisatrice Maria
Brandon avec ce film c'est de faire en
sorte que tout le monde dans le monde
entier sache que lorsqu'une femme au
Kirghizistan souhaite se libérer de ces
nouveaux proches imposées et bien la loi
est de son côté donc encore une fois on
revient sur le thème de l'éducationnel
qui est si cher au festival